what is up everybody it's annamac here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will break down how oda tricked us about
the true nature of luffy's devil fruit
from the very beginning and i will argue
that he always planned to take the story
in this direction oda's brilliant
foreshadowing over the course of 25
years all led up to this moment and it
was all right there in front of us but
more than just foreshadowing what has
already happened oda left us clues about
luffy's future ultimate power and the
final battle in the story so let's get
into it you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our one piece content and you want
to see more in the future just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with that
youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new here or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet remember that subscribing
and hitting that bell is a completely
free but very real way of directly
supporting the channel finally this
video will contain one piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned
now ever since joy boy and nika were
first introduced in one piece in
chapters 6 28 and 1018 respectively fans
have of course been speculating that
luffy will turn out to be their joy boy
or nika or both we now know that luffy
is in fact joy boy reborn and that the
true name of his devil fruit the gomu
is actually the hitohitonomi mythical
model nika this was a massive revelation
that set the one-piece fan base ablaze
and absolutely broke the internet as the
hype surrounding the latest one-piece
chapters reached historic levels the
fact that luffy would turn out to be
nika was foreshadowed through his
silhouette all the way back in skypia
and the existence of nica was also
hinted at through the sun pirates
however long before chapter 1044
and even long before skypia oda had been
teasing us with the true nature of
luffy's devil fruit in fact in order to
understand the full extent of oda's 5d
chest moves we have to go all the way
back to chapter one i got into one piece
through the manga and the first time i
saw the gomugomi in chapter 1 of the
story that spiral design on the fruit
itself caught my attention i just felt
like those spirals were put there for a
reason it wasn't just a random artistic
choice there had to be some meaning
behind it however as i read through the
manga i kind of forgot about this and
then as new devil fruits were introduced
a lot of them had some variation of a
spiral design so i just kind of took it
for granted that this is how devil
fruits look
but after the whole nika sun god reveal
and then after the events of the latest
chapters where the gomuko munyami was
thrust into the spotlight i started
looking into ancient symbols that
incorporated a similar spiral design
that is when i found out that extremely
similar spirals to the ones on the
gomugo monomi have been used by multiple
civilizations throughout history to
symbolize the sun in ancient celtic
culture in particular this type of
spiral was likely used to symbolize the
sun and the double spiral which can also
be clearly seen on luffy's devil fruit
was said to represent the sun's journey
over the course of the year with a
specific emphasis on the equinoxes now
just like with the ancient kingdom in
the world of one piece there is a lot we
still don't know about the ancient
civilizations in our own world including
the celts we simply don't know all the
specific meanings that these symbols
held for the ancient people that created
them that said some speculate that
celtic single spirals also symbolized
growth birth and the expansion of
consciousness with the double spiral
also being a symbol for balance and
equality all of these meanings make
perfect sense in the context of luffy
and his devil fruit after quote unquote
dying luffy is born again as joy boy his
devil fruit awakens and his powers and
his consciousness expands after all not
only is luffy now stronger than ever
before but the gorosei implied that in
some sense his powers are only limited
by his own imagination by his own
consciousness there was a bit of
confusion about this part because the
official this translation differs from
the unofficial one but the implication
is that the nika fruit allows
unprecedented freedom of movement and
action for its user so much so that the
fruit's power is considered to be a
godly and in some ways even ridiculous
power furthermore boy's mission dating
back to the void century was to bring
balance and equality to the world
equality to all people and races and
freedom from oppression by the world
government or its predecessors
personally i don't believe that every
single detail in the one piece manga has
some sort of profoundly important
meaning and that literally every panel
is some sort of complex puzzle that oda
intended for us to solve there is such a
thing as looking too deeply into
minuscule details and overthinking
things but with that said luffy's devil
fruit has played an incredibly important
role in the story and that role has only
become more important in the latest
chapters i believe that oda always plans
to have luffy's devil fruit awaken in
this way so i don't think it's too
far-fetched to assume that even in the
first chapter oda drew the devil fruit
with that distinctive spiral pattern for
a reason oda has clearly studied ancient
civilizations and he has implemented
many aspects of these civilizations into
the world of one piece so i'm inclined
to believe that the spiral design on the
gomu gomi aka the nika devil fruit was
an intentional clue about the fruit's
true power but as is often the case with
oda the clue was just vague enough for
us to overlook it until the big reveal
was made and then we finally understood
what oda was doing but only in hindsight
and this doesn't just stop at the design
of luffy's devil fruit in that first
chapter we also saw luffy smiling and
being full of joy after eating the fruit
even though based on everything he knew
about the devil fruit at that point in
time he probably should have been upset
about consuming it rather than being
happy after all luffy's dream was to
become a pirate and sail the high seas
and yet he just found out that he ate a
fruit which not only changed his body
forever but also prevented him from ever
being able to swim not being able to
swim is an absolutely massive handicap
for any sailor and for any pirate not
only that but luffy couldn't really
control his devil fruit powers at first
so it's not like they made him stronger
right away if anything he was taunted
for being weird and a freak due to his
rubber body and he would have to work
hard for years before he learned to
actually control his powers and yet
somehow even as a kid luffy knew that
his newfound powers were a blessing even
though most people in that part of the
world at that point in time would have
considered it a curse luffy felt joy and
he knew that everything would work out
for the best and he was already on his
way to becoming joy boy there were also
many other little hints and clues along
the way that could be considered
foreshadowing for luffy's devil fruit
being related to joy boy nika but a lot
of these were a bit of a stretch no pun
intended nevertheless now that we know
that luffy's devil fruit is not a
paramecia type but rather a mythical
zone type we have to acknowledge that
luffy's attacks and gears were actually
major clues about the true nature of his
devil fruit power initially most of
luffy's attacks were named after weapons
like the gomugamuno pistol and
gomugomuno rocket and this was based on
the fact that back in the first chapter
luffy claimed that his punch was as
powerful as a pistol but then later on
and especially after the time skip we
get more and more techniques named after
animals including a hawk elephant
grizzly python cobra hydra and so on
interestingly enough that most recent
one hydra is a creature from greek
mythology so a mythical animal and then
we have luffy's different forms or gears
these very distinct forms or
transformations were always more in line
with the workings of a zone fruit than
the workings of a paramecia however this
was just overlooked by many because
luffy's devil fruit was assumed to be a
special paramecia like katakuri's
furthermore the fact that luffy's true
power may only be limited by his own
imagination was also hinted at
previously for example in gear third
luffy is able to inflate his bones by
blowing air into his body but your bones
are not actually connected to each other
in a way that would allow air to pass
from one bone to the other and inflate
it so this technique was always more of
a feat of luffy's imagination than
something that made sense in a logical
or scientific way on top of that
throughout the series luffy appears to
be incorporating the techniques of his
rivals into his own powers and abilities
like when he reinterprets the rokushiki
abilities and uses them in his own
attacks this again implies that luffy's
devil fruit ability is not stagnant
rather it is evolving and expanding as
luffy's own experience and imagination
evolve and expand in the past it has
been stated that zone type fruits are
exceptional in terms of their toughness
and recovery speed i believe it was
actually crocodile who said this and if
we look at luffy's abilities it is clear
that his recovery speed and toughness
matches that description but with luffy
being a shonen protagonist i feel like
most of us just assumed that this was
part of his protagonist powers now there
were other clues about luffy's true
power that were more on the nose like
for example the color spread of chapter
1028 which features the straw hats as
gamers slash video game characters on
this page luffy appears to be
representing ken from street fighter but
if you take a closer look at his hair it
is clearly foreshadowing what his hair
will look like in gear 5th so yeah i am
inclined to believe that oda had the
nika fruit in mind since the very
beginning and that he has been teasing
us with it for nearly 25 years that is
definitely a 5d chess move if i ever saw
one but it gets better because we know
that oda has been teasing us and giving
us clues about luffy's true powers since
the beginning it's likely that there are
still more clues out there about the
full extent of his ultimate power that
we are yet to identify in other words
oda may have already told us what full
power luffy will be capable of and how
the story will ultimately end first
let's talk about rubber hose animation
the old animation style that clearly
inspired luffy's new gear 5th abilities
this animation style dates all the way
back to the 1920s and 30s and it is
considered to be the first animation
style that became a standardized style
in america the style is known for
featuring characters whose arms and legs
seem to have the properties of a rubber
hose they can move wildly and they don't
appear to have any bones joints or
wrists essentially this allowed the
characters to move in completely
unrealistic ways and their movements
were not bound by the confines of
science or biology if you heard of
cuphead then you know what rubber hose
animation is because cuphead itself is
an homage to this animation style
although rubber hose animation fell out
of favor as more realistic animation
styles were developed in the 1930s many
of its quote-unquote unrealistic
elements were carried over to future
animations and they are present in such
popular cartoons as the looney tunes
we've all seen those crazy effects when
a cartoon character's eyes pop out of
their head when they're surprised or
scared or the character pulls a giant
thing out of their pockets that couldn't
possibly fit there or the character
pulls up the entire floor from under
them or the character walks calmly on
air and he doesn't fall until the moment
that he realizes that there's nothing
under him road runner tom and jerry bux
bunny daffy duck scooby-doo and many
other classic cartoons are full of this
type of stuff luffy's new powers gear
5th or doneka devil fruit awakening are
clearly based on this type of animation
and actually in chapter 1044 we saw
luffy's eyes pop out we saw him turning
the floor into rubber and pulling it up
from under him to rebound kaido's attack
we saw his limbs temporarily growing to
a ridiculous size and so on this is
certainly an instance of oda paying
tribute to rubber hose animation and it
also adds a brand new flavor to the
story as a whole and to luffy's fighting
style in particular but oda didn't pick
this power just because he liked the art
style there is more to it than that and
this is another thing that has been
hinted at for a very long time in the
story the gorosei state that the power
of the nika fruit is not just possessing
a body with the properties of rubber
although that is a big part of it once
it awakens the nika fruit allows its
user to fight in any way he wants and he
has an incredible amount of strength and
freedom as i mentioned earlier the
user's power is connected to the power
of his own imagination but this devil
fruit had not awakened for over 800
years not since the void century this is
likely because its previous users did
not have the drive and the imagination
to initiate the fruit awakening but
luffy has always had that drive ever
since the very beginning he had big
dreams ever since he was a little kid he
wanted to become the pirate king and the
freest man on the sea and it is this
massive dream that has been guiding him
all this time this dream has given him
the drive to overcome insane obstacles
surpass his limits and do the impossible
in the pursuit of true freedom and that
is why the nika fruit awakened in this
moment
for the first time since joy boy the
nika fruit found a user who has the
vision imagination and determination to
unlock its true power and potential
so in my opinion luffy's new cartoonish
power wasn't just a stylistic choice by
oda gear fifth literally represents true
freedom and not just freedom in the
conventional sense it's not just freedom
to do whatever you want without someone
else stopping you gear fifth symbolizes
freedom from all restraints even the
restraints of reality itself the best
way that i can explain this is by
referring to zen buddhism which has
certainly been a clear inspiration for
oda over the course of the series now i
am not a zen master but i do practice
zazen and this is how i understand it
true freedom means complete
non-attachment it means truly letting go
of everything and this doesn't just mean
letting go of all your material
possessions which is merely the first
step for monks who decide to leave home
and embrace a monastic life letting go
of everything means letting go of all
conceptual thinking all attachment to
quote unquote reality when we say that
something is realistic it means that it
matches up with all of our preconceived
notions about what is possible and
impossible scientific and unscientific
logical and illogical but what if those
preconceived notions did not exist what
if you were like a newborn child
completely free from all classifications
definitions and limitations what if you
looked at the world with a completely
clear and open mind what if the sentence
the birds are flying through the sky and
the sentence the fish are dancing in the
trees were both the same thing to you
and one was not more or less plausible
than the other that would be true
freedom nothing to hold on to nothing to
limit you nothing to classify you or be
classified by you no biases no
preconceived notions no concepts at all
just infinite possibility that is the
true nature of luffy's new power the
power of infinite potential with luffy's
childish innocence and endless
determination it goes without saying
that he will be able to take his new
abilities to incredible heights and the
better he gets at using this power the
more he may be able to warp reality
itself and shape it according to his own
whims which will make him a practically
unstoppable fighter that said there will
almost certainly be some serious
drawbacks to luffy using this insanely
broken power otherwise he would become
too strong and the story would become
boring if you're interested in what
kinds of drawbacks luffy might
experience until he learns to truly
master gear 5th check out my video in
which i talked about the possibility
that luffy's devil fruit could be
devouring him from the inside link in
the description but assuming that luffy
will learn to control and master his new
power who could possibly challenge him
now who can stand against an awakened
devil fruit with the power of a literal
god a power that allows its user to bend
reality itself could there be other
devil fruits out there with straight up
godly powers that are able to actually
challenge luffy's newfound abilities and
make the story even more interesting as
we approach the final epic arcs well we
just recently dropped a video here on
the channel which speculated that
blackbeard may also have a mythical zone
fruit with a power that is equal to and
the perfect counterpart of luffy's sun
god the devil fruit in the past
blackbeard has straight up said that his
devil fruit is the most dangerous power
in the history of all devil fruits and
he also said that his devil fruit chose
him as if it had a will of its own we
already know that blackbeard's devil
fruit possesses properties that are not
consistent with its classification as a
logia for example blackbeard cannot use
his devil fruit to avoid attacks by
letting them just pass through him which
is something that every skilled logia
user should be able to do so far we just
assumed that he has a special logia in
the same way that many of us assumed
that luffy had a special paramecia but
we all know how that turned out knowing
how similar luffy's and blackbeard's
devil fruits are in appearance
i wouldn't be surprised if blackbeard
lied about his devil fruit being a logia
in order to mislead everyone about its
true power and potential what if his
real devil fruit is a mythical zone that
grants him the power of a god just like
luffy's only his might be the moon god
or the god of darkness or something
along those lines if you want to examine
this concept in greater detail check out
the full video on blackbeard's real
devil fruit power link in the
description let me know what you guys
think down in the comments are there
more devil fruits out there with godly
powers like luffy's nika devil fruit and
if so is luffy going to have to face off
against them at some point in the future
will blackbeard turned out to be luffy's
ultimate rival the man with a devil
fruit as strong as his own don't forget
to leave your thoughts i always like
hearing from you if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more one
piece content right here on the channel
please leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot with
that youtube algorithm and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys